price of cryptocurrency bitcoin has hit
a record new high of 23
000 we can report the price is up than
just in the last month and more than 200
this year
bitcoin's reputation as digital gold has
grown with several high profile
investors naming it as an emerging
inflation hedge
financial expert and rt host max kaiser
told us why he thinks it's a stable
investment even in this pandemic
bitcoin it was going to go to 400 000 a
coin
regardless of what what the situation is
with the pandemic or regardless of what
the
situation is between nation states
because it will trade similar to a
market capitalization of gold
the poverty is caused by paper money and
bitcoin solves the problem of
poverty uh how does bitcoin fix the
problem
it decapitalizes the banks it
decapitalizes the central banks
it puts them out of business because
everybody is their own bank
no paper money has ever survived ever in
history
over the past 300 years every single
form of paper money
has either gone completely bankrupt or
lost
99 of its value none have ever worked
it's impossible to work paper money it's
a
it's a faulty idea so we only have
really
gold but in the 21st century bitcoin is
better than gold so bitcoin is actually
pushing gold off the world stage
people are buying bitcoin not gold
because it's superior to gold
and that's the inflection point that
we're on in the 21st century
we're witnessing a remarkable
transformation of the global economy
right now this year it's incredible
you